Sure, if the cancer is spreading, I know only a biopsy could be a hundred percent diagnosed want to poke more holes into it. Yeah, totally agree.
Is there a time to consider conventional treatments? Yes, I do. There's always a time to consider. I think you should consider it all the time.
But again, that's where you're praying about your decision and asking God to, hey, do I need to do something else?
And again, maybe God's going to lead you to do something else. I've said this hundred times before, God wanted, you know, I need to do chemo for the sole reason to witness to some chemo nurse, I would have done it.
But, you know, in my prayer time and prayer life, praying about what I should do, I just felt like that he was not leading me down that pathway.
So, and you don't want to be, I've said this thousand times before, you don't want to be dogmatically positioned like, I would never do chemo ever, ever. I just don't think that's wise.
I mean, you got to be open to, you know, to be wise in your decision. I've seen patients that, you know, did chemo. And that's what saved their life is doing that chemo.
Maybe they didn't have to follow through it every six, you know, sessions or 12 sessions, but doing a little bit help knock it down.
And I've also seen people that got right into doing something like that, that was their demise. So don't use that fear, don't make any decision based upon your don't make a decision based upon being dogmatically positioned either say, you know, hey, you know, I'm going to do what I need to do.
I'm going to use wisdom. But if I move it in the right directions and I'm going to keep moving in the right direction. So.